is that hard for you like you get close
to guys even like a guy on the movie
like Sean Penn and stuff right and you
start to believe like wow
you know this is a great family we're
friends right and then it stops and then
like you never hear from anyone again I
think there's an emotional component
that's difficult how are you very
perceptive in that way you know it's
very true but a long time ago I used to
get so [__] up over that because I was
doing a uh play and I I had been with
these people and I had you know been
friends with them and lovers and just
you know had this like incredible like
kind of closeness and then it ended and
it and I was devastated it's sad because
you think to yourself this really is my
best friend this really is my mom this
really is my my my my wife or my
girlfriend or whatever that thing is
yeah and then it's over and nobody's in
touch with you I know and you have to
you have to get through that and say to
yourself look if friendship
is different than acting you know what I
mean and if it's me if you're meant to
be friends you'll find each other down
the road if you're if you're not then
you'll just cross paths again and it's
going to be okay and you have to find
the real things outside of the movies
you have to find real friends you got to
find real wives you gotta find real
parents you know all those things that
you need has to exist outside because
you think that's what happened with you
and Kira because you were in a play
together when you met her you guys got
married right like you were able to take
someone from the play right and continue
on but we weren't playing we weren't
playing lovers in the play so what you
know I mean I think that yeah I mean
look I mean we met doing it and and I
probably if you had asked me at that
point in my life I would have said I
don't want to be with an actress but you
know the that's just this kind of a
stroke of luck that we found somebody we
wanted to hang out with when I did
private parts that was my only
experience with a real movie I I was
depressed for months afterwards I missed
Betty Thomas the director I mean in a
real way I miss seeing those people
I loved it yeah I really went and got
sad yeah it's it's it's interesting you
know but you but you had it on there for
as many movies as I've done you know I I
protect myself I'd have this kind of
thing where I just I start to go okay
it's pull away time you know now I need
to you know now I need to just get my
head away from this this group and start
to get back to you know the real
spectacular my own kids my own wife my
own friends you know that's hard and
then sometimes you make friends and
sometimes all of a sudden because a lot
of my friends I have have met on movies
you know